okay so let me ask what does the United
States Liberia and Myanmar have in
common well these are really the only
three nations that have yet to fully
embrace the metric system here in the
United States there are certain areas
within our maybe government and society
that have gone metric but in everyday
life we still kind of hold on to the
English measuring system or the Imperial
measuring system so this video is gonna
talk about you know just what the metric
system is so let me a first asking do
you need a calculator to answer the
following questions and if you look at
these questions I hope you realize no
you shouldn't look at the first one five
times 1,000 you see the three zeroes on
the 1000 just put them after the five
and you got your answer look at the next
one see the 10 there's only one zero on
the 10 so put that one zero at the end
of 375 and you get three thousand seven
hundred and fifty well what about the
next one
625 divided by 100 I hope you see all
you have to do is move the decimal point
and you get six point two five and then
finally the last one the 1000 there's
three zeroes in a 1000 1000 so we just
move the decimal point three places and
you get point zero four six if you can
do these problems without a calculator
and you should then you can you can do
the metric system it's really this
simple so let's get started so first of
all here's the metric scale and well
there's a portion of the metric scale
and I want to mention that the metric
system is really based on factors of ten
so I'll talk about what I mean by the
basic unit in a moment but what's ten
times bigger than one well that would be
ten what's ten times bigger than ten
that would be 100 what's ten times
bigger than 100 that would be 1,000 I
hope you see what I mean by the metric
system is based on factors of ten well
let's go the opposite direction on the
scale
what's ten times smaller than one that
would be 1/10 or 0.1 what's ten times
smaller than the ten
that would be a hundred or point zero
one
well what's ten times smaller than that
that would be a thousand or point zero
zero one notice again the metric system
is based on factors of ten and so let's
start looking at the length if you're
gonna measure the length of something
the distance from one point to another
point you imagine how long something is
let's talk about that so first of all
the basic unit of measuring length in
the metric system is only built around
something called a meter so let me
change notice how my scale has changed
the basic unit is now labeled one meter
well what's ten meters that would be a
deca meter
what's a hundred meters that would be a
hectometer
what's a thousand meters that would be a
kilometer go the opposite direction on
the scale what's 1/10 of a meter that
would be a decimeter what's a hundredth
of a meter that would be a centimeter
and what's a thousandth of a meter that
would be a millimeter and so you might
be used to measuring things and feets
and yards and inches and miles
these are not metric I mentioned at the
very beginning of the video certain
areas of the United States have gone
metric but mainly our culture is still
built around the Imperial metric excuse
me the Imperial measuring system and so
feet yards inches miles these are part
of the Imperial or the English measuring
system so if I were to if I were to
measure the distance between these two
cities maybe Los Angeles City a in
Chicago Illinois City B I'd probably
want to use a big measuring device
because there's a big distance between
these two cities so I'm gonna use
probably kilometers to measure and I
actually looked this up on Google Maps
and it comes to approximately 3,200
kilometers between Chicago and Los
Angeles so I'd want to use a big
measuring stick but if I measuring
something smaller like a tree now a tree
might only be 15 to
feet tall depending on the species of a
tree so I'm not gonna use a kilometer to
measure a tree it's like I'm not going
to use a mile to measure the height of a
tree I want something smaller in this
case I'd probably just use a meter and
this tree may very well only be you know
seven or eight meters tall depending
upon the species of the tree okay well
here's a practice problem pretend an
object is two meters tall if I were to
ask you to convert that how many
centimeters is that well this is where
the beauty of the metric system I hope
is on display all I have to do is move
the decimal point notice in the scale
centimeters is two places to the right
so if I move the decimal point one place
to the right I can say two meters is the
same thing as twenty decimeters but if I
move the decimal point another place to
the right and then I can say two meters
is the same thing as 200 centimeters and
I've got my answer I don't need a
calculator
I'm just moving decimal points here's
another one
pretend an object is 475 millimeters
tall how many meters would that be how
many meters you can see I have to move
the decimal to the left if I move the
decimal one place to the left I would
have forty seven point five centimeters
if I move the decimal point another
place to the left I would have four
point seven five decimeters so I have to
move the decimal point one more place to
the left and I have 0.475 meters that's
my answer
you see all I'm doing is moving a
decimal point left or right depending on
the problem I'm trying to solve
okay so I've kind of reset my scale here
now a moment ago we were measuring in
meters but that's because we were
measuring the length of something what
if I'm trying to measure the mass how
much we matter an object has you know
measure its weight
well it's mass and then I'd want to use
of the basic unit would be a gram so
watch how my scale changes the basic
unit of mass is a gram so 1010 grams
would be a deca gram hundred grams would
be f hectogram a thousand grams would be
a kilogram moved to the other side of
the scale a tenth of a gram would be a
deci gram a hundredth of a gram would be
a centigram and the thousandth of a gram
would be a milligram now you might be
used to measuring things in pounds and
tons and ounces but these aren't metric
again these are part of the Imperial
measuring system and you might be more
familiar with these if you've grown up
here in the United States but these are
not metric so what if we're trying to
measure how heavy an automobile is well
automobiles are pretty heavy I'm gonna
want to use a big measuring device I'd
probably choose a kilogram to measure
the weight of an automobile but what if
I was taking a medicine pill let's say I
had a sickness and I was taking a
medicine pill to try to get better
well medicine pills are often measured
in milligrams a medicine pills not very
big so I don't need a big measuring
device I'm gonna choose the measuring
unit that is best in this situation well
let's do a practice problem pretend an
object weighs 500 grams if I were to ask
you how many hepta grams that is again
here you can see the full beauty of the
metric system it's really based on
powers of 10 factors of 10 and so I'm
just moving decimal points if I move the
decimal point one place to the left I
would have 50 decagrams but if I move
the decimal point another place to the
left I would have five hecta grams so
500 grams is the same thing as five
hecta grams it's really that
straightforward
well notice I've reset the scale so
let's look at the next basic unit what
about measuring volume the amount of
space that an object occupies on that
case the basic unit will be a leader so
watch how the scale changes and the
basic unit is a leader so 10 liters
would be a deca leader a hundred leaders
would be a hectolitre a thousand leaders
would be a killer leader move to the
other side now a tenth of a leader would
be a deciliter a hundredth of a leader
would be a centiliter and a thousandth
of a leader would be a milliliter now
you might be used to measuring things in
gallons and quarts and cups and
teaspoons and tablespoons again these
are not metric these are part of the
English measuring system or the Imperial
measuring system these are not metrics
we're not gonna be using these if I was
trying to measure how much water was in
the swimming pool you know a swimming
pool can hold a lot of water so I want
to use a big measuring unit such as a
killer liter if I wanted to know how
much air is in this hot air balloon
you know this hot air balloon can
probably hold a whole lot of air I'd
probably also choose kiloliters but in
biology class you know we often measure
things in in milliliters small amount of
volumes with a graduated cylinder as
we're doing various labs and experiments
and so I'd probably use a graduated
cylinder to measure some a small amount
of liquid in milliliters now if we do a
practice problem pretend a container
holds 15 deca litres of it of water
well how many centiliters is this again
you can see the beauty of the metric
system I just have to move the decimal
point if I move the decimal point one
place to the right I would have a
hundred and fifty liters if I move
another place to the right I would have
1,500 deciliters and so if I move the
decimal point one more place to the
right I would have 15,000 centiliters
that's my final answer you notice all I
did was move a decimal point no need for
a calculator
so let's do a few practice problems
before we're done which metric unit
would be best for measuring the mass of
this bulldozer
you know pause the video think about it
from these choices when you're ready hit
the play button I'm gonna go over the
answer in three two one
so first of all let's cross off tunz
tunz is not a metric unit tons is one of
those imperial units now I'm gonna cross
off kiloliters next because kiloliters
measures volume anything in leaders
measures volume and we're not trying to
measure volume we're trying to measure
the mass I can now cross off centimeters
cuz any kind of meter is gonna measure
distance I'm not trying to measure the
distance of this bulldozer I'm trying to
measure it how heavier its mass and so
now I've got my last two choices notice
how one choice is just a gram in one
choice is a kilogram while bulldozer is
really heavy so I'm gonna want to choose
a big measuring device so gram is just
too small I could measure this bulldozer
in grams but my answer is gonna be a
really really really big number so let
me use a big measuring device a kilogram
so here's a practice problem right now
pause the video try to answer the the
question and then hit the play button
when you're ready I'm gonna go over the
answer in three two one
okay well here's the metric scale in
case you needed it and if I know 8.4
hecta meters and I'm trying to turn it
into kilometers notice how it's only one
place away if I move the decimal one
point one decimal place to the left I
would have my answer of point eight four
and that's the beauty of the metric
system we're just moving decimal points
now this is not a metric problem this is
kind of an analogy first so which of
these is most valuable ten excuse me
twelve dimes 12 dimes 20 nickels for
three quarters now if you're not used to
American currency then this is probably
a hard problem but if you are used to
American currency you might know let's
turn these all into dollars twelve dimes
is the same thing as a dollar twenty
twenty Mickle's is the same thing as one
dollar and three quarters is the same
thing as seventy five cents or point
seventy five dollars and so now that
they've all been turned into the same
unit they're all now labeled in dollars
you can see that the dimes were the most
valuable so why am I giving you this
problem because this is an analogy to
the next one so look at this practice
problem which of these three numbers is
the largest try to answer it pause the
video hit the play button when you're
ready to check your answer I'm gonna go
over the answer in three two one
well I hope you see why I use that money
example from a moment ago cuz right now
one of these numbers is in kilograms
ones and grams and ones and centigrams
let's make them all the same unit so
here's my metric scale if you want to
refer to this let's make them all grams
now the middle one is already in grams
775 grams but if I turn point eight
kilograms into grams that would be 800
grams the bottom one 1225 centigrams if
I turn that into grams I convert that it
would be twelve point two five grams so
now that all three numbers are in the
same unit of gram I can see that the
zero point eight kilogram was the
biggest of the three numbers that I gave
you even though it might not have looked
the biggest zero point eight looks like
a small number but kilo gram kilo is a
big measuring unit so as we wrap up this
video if you're in my class you know
maybe hit the pause button and try to
answer these questions on a separate
sheet of paper I'd be happy to check
your answer and I hope you found this
video helpful thanks for watching